let's look at the heating curve for
water a heating curve has temperature
on the y-axis in this case we have it in
degrees celsius
and heat added on the x-axis let's say
it's in kilojoules
let's say we have 18.0 grams of ice and
our goal is to calculate the total heat
necessary to convert that 18 grams of
ice
at negative 25 degrees celsius to
steam at 125 degrees celsius
so we're starting with ice at negative
25 degrees celsius and first we need to
heat
up the ice to zero degrees celsius which
we know is the melting point
so on our heating curve we're going from
point a to
point b to calculate the heat necessary
we need to use the equation
q is equal to m c delta t
where q is the heat added m is the mass
of the ice
c is the specific heat of ice and delta
t is the change in temperature which is
the final temperature
minus the initial temperature so we're
trying to calculate q
and we know the mass of our ice is 18.0
grams the specific heat of ice
is 2.03
joules per gram degree celsius
and for the change in temperature it's
final minus initial so the final
temperature would be
zero degrees celsius initial is negative
25 so 0 minus negative 25
gives us positive 25
degrees celsius so grams will cancel out
degrees celsius cancels out
and this gives us q is equal to
9.1 times 10
to the second joules to two significant
figures
or we could also write 0.91
kilojoules now that the ice is at zero
degrees celsius we know it's going to
melt so we're going to go from point
b on the heating curve to point c
and to calculate how much heat is
necessary to melt the ice
we need to know the heat of fusion of
ice which is equal to
6.01
kilojoules per mole
so we need to figure out how many moles
of ice we have
well we're starting with 18.0 grams
we divide by the molar mass of h2o which
is 18.0
grams per mole and the grams will cancel
and give us one mole so we have 1.00
moles of ice and we multiply that by
6.01 kilojoules per mole
and the moles cancel out and give us
6.01
kilojoules now that all the ice is
melted we have liquid water
and so on our heating curve we're going
to heat that liquid water from 0 degrees
celsius
to 100 degrees celsius which is the
boiling point of water
so we're going from point c to point d
on the heating curve
to calculate the heat added we use the q
is equal to
m c delta t equation again
so we're solving for q the mass is still
18.0 grams
but the specific heat now since we have
liquid water we need to use the specific
heat of liquid water which is 4.18
joules per gram degrees celsius
and for the change in temperature the
final temperature is
100 so 100 minus 0
gives us positive 100
degrees celsius so grams cancel out
degrees celsius cancels out and we find
that
q is equal to 7.52
times 10 to the third
joules just correct that three there
7.52 times 10 to the third joules
which is equal to 7.52
kilojoules once we reach point d in the
heating curve
we're at the boiling point of water so
the heat that we add now is going to go
into turning the liquid water into
gaseous water
so going from point d to point e we're
doing a phase change we need to know the
heat of vaporization
of water and that's equal to 40.7
kilojoules per mole
and we already know we have one mole
of h2o so one mole times 40.7 moles the
moles cancel
and it takes 40 40.7 kilojoules
of energy to convert the liquid water
into gaseous water
or steam next we're going to heat the
gaseous water from 100 degrees celsius
to 125 degrees celsius so we're going
from
point e to point f on the heating curve
and to figure out how much heat
we need to add we use the q is equal to
m c delta t
equation one more time so we're solving
for q
and we still have 18.0 grams
this time we need to use the specific
heat of steam which is 1.84
joules per gram degree celsius
the change in temperature would be 125
minus 100
or positive 25 degrees
celsius so grams cancel units cancel out
and we get q is equal to 8.3
times 10 to the second joules to two
significant figures
which is equal to 0.83
kilojoules
finally we need to add everything up so
going from point
a to point b on the heating curve so
think about just the x-axis this time
all right so going from point a to point
b we calculated that
to be equal to 0.91
kilojoules and then from point b to
point
c we calculate that to be 6.01
kilojoules from c to d
so this distance here was 7.5
to from d to e this was the uh this was
the big one here this was equal to
40.7 40.7 kilojoules and finally from e
to f
we calculated this was equal to point
eight three point eight three kilojoules
and when you add everything up
this is equal to fifty six point
zero kilojoules so that's how much
energy
it takes to convert 18.0 grams of ice
at negative 25 degrees celsius to
gaseous water at 125 degrees celsius
next let's think about the slopes of the
different lines on our heating curve
so let's look at the line going from b
to c
and also the line going from point
d to point e both of these lines
represent phase changes
going from point b to point c was going
from a solid to a liquid
and going from point d to e was going
from a liquid to a gas
and since the slope of both of these
lines is zero that means as you add
as you add heat on the x-axis the
temperature doesn't
change so during a phase change all the
energy goes into disrupting the
intermolecular forces that are present
and they don't go into increasing the
temperature so there's no
increase in temperature during the phase
change
think about going from point d to point
e this was converting our liquid water
into gaseous water
so as as the heat is being added all
that energy
goes into breaking the intermolecular
forces between water molecules and
pulling apart those liquid water
molecules and turning them
into gaseous water molecules so it's
only after
all of the liquid water molecules are
converted into gaseous water molecules
that's when we see the temperature
increase again so talking about from
point e
to point f everything is now in the
gaseous state
and then we see the increase in
temperature finally let's compare the
slope of the line
from a to b to the slope of the line
from
c to d if we look at it the slope of the
line from a to b
is a little bit steeper than the slope
of the line
from c to d the reason for the different
slopes has to do with the different
specific heats
from a to b we use the specific heat for
ice which is 2.03 joules per gram degree
celsius
from c to d in our calculation we use
the specific heat for water which is
4.18
joules per gram degree celsius the
higher the value for the specific heat
the more energy it takes to raise the
temperature of a substance by a certain
amount
so if we think about comparing these two
let's say we try to raise the
temperature of ice by
25 degrees celsius so think about this
distance here
on the y-axis we would have to put in
only a small amount of energy
to get ice to increase its temperature
by 25 degrees celsius
we think about that same temperature
change on liquid water so if we tried to
increase the temperature of liquid water
by that same
amount 25 degrees we would have to put
in
more energy so on the x-axis
we have to put in more energy to
accomplish the same change in
temperature
and that's because liquid water has a
higher specific heat
since it might be a little bit hard to
see on that diagram let's think about
let's think about putting some heat into
a substance here so let me just draw a
horizontal line
and then we're trying to accomplish a
certain temperature change so i'll draw
a vertical line
those two give me those two give me a
line
with a slope so let's say we're trying
to accomplish the same
change in temperature so i'll draw this
y distance the same as before
but we have a higher specific heat so it
takes more
takes more energy therefore this x
distance is going to
increase and when we increase the x
distance
we see that the slope decreases
so the greater the value for the
specific heat
the lower the slope on the heating curve